the man who drove his SUV through a
Christmas parade in Waukesha Wisconsin
last year now faces life in prison Daryl
Brooks was convicted yesterday of six
counts of intentional homicide and 61
counts of reckless endangerment plus
nine other charges six people were
killed and dozens more were injured in
the attack we warn you the video is
disturbing Roxanna Siberia is outside
the courthouse in Waukesha just west of
Milwaukee Roxanna good morning
good morning Nate Daryl Brooks
represented himself in a three-week
trial that saw him clash with the judge
on several occasions in the end the jury
deliberated for just over three hours
before reaching its verdict
we the jury find the defendant Daryl e
Brooks guilty a first degree intentional
homicide Daryl Brooks hung his head as
the judge read that 76 guilty verdicts
one man was removed from Court after
that Outburst we are satisfied that this
defendant has been held accountable for
his actions The 40-Year-Old was
convicted of driving his Ford Escape
through a Christmas parade in Waukesha
Wisconsin on November 21st he killed six
people and wounded dozens more Ryan
conkey's Niece jessalyn Taurus was badly
injured in the parade what do you think
this decision will mean for the healing
of families like yours and other
families I think it's a huge step
forward you know I think this gives
everybody an opportunity to have some
sort of closure 79-year-old Virginia
Sorensen was performing with her troop
the dancing grannies when she was killed
after the verdict her son Marshall
recalled his mom's favorite saying
angels watch over you my five-year-old
daughter came up to me and handed me
this necklace with my Mom's ashes in it
and she told me to take my mom
with us for the sentencing so she was
with us today
the judge set a date for a set of
hearing for Monday to schedule a date
for sentencing Brooks can appeal his
convictions Tony
all right Roxanna thank you very much